[Music]
how are you how's your life how's your
family how's you you have two kids is
that i am i can't complain got uh
gorgeous beautiful kids in my life
actually i can complain
because what i didn't anticipate when
when i had these little babies with my
wife
was that there would be so much stress
about where they're going to go to
school yeah they they're getting to that
age the oldest one's five and it's
kindergarten time
and there's this one and you just want
to make a good impression
and there's a hebrew school that we
really liked and i feel a little
hypocritical because i'm an atheist you
know but but it's a really good school
and i am a jew technically we you know
i'm i'm allowed to take my kids there
right and my wife is too but also we've
not been to synagogue for years so
i was kind of feeling the pressure to
show that i'm a good jew and i was
putting on a little bit of a show
you were really you were listening i was
just saying you know i do have some
experience with the the
the uh uh the high holy days and the
passover seder and i was and they were
saying yeah so what's uh what's passover
like at the home of the blacks and we
were like uh
yeah it's good we used my wife's uh
grandfather's haggadah which is true and
uh and i said the only thing is it's
missing that last song the chad gadiad
which was my favorite as a kid and uh
you know and i sang a little bit of it
for him and it was really shameful
because were you kind of making it up or
was it no no it's legit it's legit but i
was really playing it up how into it i
am and and as we were leaving uh i was
uh still singing a little bit of that
leather
and uh they were like okay that's good
and we were leaving and i could see the
other parents that were waiting in line
were looking at us very judgmentally
like you don't really care about
passover
but uh did you find the song pretty
catchy as a songwriter and a musician
did you do you like the song i actually
do love that song and it it it's a
it's kind of like the original heavy
metal song
because really well it's all about you
know the chain of life and it starts off
with a little goat that father brought
fortune and uh the goat was it was eaten
by the cat who was bit by the dog
and it goes all the way up the chain up
to the angel of death
that slayed the ox
and i remember there was like little
illustrations when i was a kid i was
obsessed with the angel of death it was
very black sabbath
that's where i first got this would be a
black sabbath song yeah exactly